NIGHT AT SEVEN.
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND, EVERYBODY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT, THE PRESIDENT IS ABOUT TO
SPEAK TO HIS SUPPORTERS IN
TUPELO, MISSISSIPPI.
WE JUST GOT WORD HE'S IN THE
VEHICLE ON THE HIS WAY TO THE
RALLY.
IT'S HIS FIRST PUBLIC EVENT
SINCE THE HOUSE VOTED ON
IMPEACHMENT SO I'M CERTAIN HE
WILL HAVE TO SOMETHING TO SAY
ABOUT THAT.
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO THE
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IT WAS JUST THIS PAST SPRING
BELIEVE IT OR NOT THAT IT WILL
ROCK SUMMED UP THERE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL PRESIDENTIAL RACE
THIS WAY.
"LIKE, THIS IS THE FIGHT OF OUR
LIVES AS AMERICANS AND HUMANS.
YOU CAN PROBABLY TELL I WANT TO
RUN, HE TOLD "VANITY FAIR" AT
THE TIME.
I THINK I'D BE GOOD AT IT.
MANY IN THE NATIONAL MEDIA
AGREED AND THOUGHT HE WOULD BE
GOOD AT IT, TOO.
TURNS OUT HE WASN'T.
HE QUIT THE PRESIDENTIAL RACE
TODAY AFTER THOROUGHLY
COMMITTING, HUMILIATING HIMSELF.
WE JUST TOLD YOU THE PRESIDENT
IS SCHEDULED TO START SPEAKING
THIS HOUR FROM THE MISSISSIPPI
AND WE EXPECT THERE WILL BE SOME
NEWS MADE DURING THAT EVENT.
NO MATTER WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAYS OR DOESN'T SAY,
MANY IN OUR MANAGERIAL CLASS
WILL VEHEMENTLY DISAPPROVE.
THEY DESPISE DONALD TRUMP ON
PRINCIPLE AND LOATHE EVERYTHING
ABOUT HIM FROM HIS MANNERISMS TO
HIS NATO POLICY AND EVERYTHING
IN BETWEEN.
UNDERNEATH IT ALL WHAT THEY
REALLY HATE IS THE FACT THAT HE
IS A NATIONALIST.
AND EVEN WORSE, HE ADMITS IT.
>> President Trump: THEY HAVE
A WORD, IT SORT OF BECAME
OLD-FASHIONED.
IT'S CALLED A NATIONALIST.
AND I SAID REALLY, WE ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO USE THAT WORD.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I AM?
AND NATIONALIST.
>> Tucker: HE CROSSED THE LINE
THERE.
NATIONALIST?
AND HE WILL TELL YOU THAT FROM A
RIGIDLY SEGREGATED NEIGHBORHOOD.
IN CABLE NEWS THE TERM WAS
BASICALLY BANNED AND CONSIDERED
A VICIOUS LAWYER.
NATIONALIST.
>> USE THAT WORD.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT WORD
TONIGHT.
>> HE IS WEAPONIZED RACES,
NATIONALISM AND DOG WHISTLES.
>> YOU ARE SUGGESTING THERE'S
SOME KIND OF DOG WHISTLE THERE?
BECO IT IS, AND IT DOES PROVOKE
HATE ACTIVITY.
>> AMERICANS KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
IT'S NOT EVEN A DOG WHISTLE
ANYMORE, IT'S A BULLHORN.
>> Tucker: GOT THAT?
A DOG WHISTLE.
IN D.C., THAT'S BAD.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE THERE IS A
CAT PERSON APPARENTLY.